hey youtubers it's Charlie so we finally
got an official series premiere date for
Sherlock series 3 so I thought I'd do a
quick update with my top five things to
look forward to in the new season along
with some of the other videos that I'm
going to be doing be sure to subscribe
to get everything I'm also going to be
doing a special holiday giveaway in the
next couple of weeks but important
things first so people in the UK you
will be able to watch episode 1 of
sherlock season 3 starting january first
each new episode 2 and 3 will premiere
each week after that people everywhere
else including North America will have
to wait till January nineteenth for that
first episode so here's what's going to
happen because I'm going to be watching
starting January first and i'll be
posting review videos right after each
episode airs I'll try not to go too
crazy with spoilers but i'll be doing at
least one to two videos per week once it
comes back also be doing some bonus
Sherlock videos in December to help us
get ready in case you haven't seen it
i've already done an actual spoilery
video for season 3 i'll have a link to
that at the end of the video as well as
in the description but now here are my
top 5 things to look forward to in
Sherlock series 3 number 5 the fall so
listening to sure like explain exactly
how he survived at the end of season two
is going to be amazing whenever Sherlock
explains things they also use some
really cool looking graphics on screen
to to show his mind Palace as it were in
the timeline series 3 picks up two years
after the events of the season 2 finale
so Watson has moved on and it's going to
be a very tense reunion because he's
believed Sherlock to be dead this whole
time number four sure lolly so like I
said Watson believe Sherlock was dead
this whole time so when he finds out he
was alive he's not too happy that means
that Sherlock has to find someone else
to go out on crime scenes with him enter
Molly Hooper she was also an integral
part to him faking his death at the end
of season 2 number 3 the mustache so if
you've seen the trailers you have seen
Watson is sporting the most spectacular
of moustaches and no he is not
celebrating Movember remember it's been
two years so there's been a lot of
changes in his life but you can expect a
big part of their reunion to revolve
around mustache related comedy number to
the ladies and Sherlock's life so the
success of Sherlock as a show as well as
as a character is really dependent upon
the strength of the supporting
characters and sure
has some amazing women in his life
obviously there's mrs. Hudson and Molly
Hooper who I already talked about but
there's Irene Adler and now Molly more
stand in this season those last two are
actually really important for this new
season as well as going forward Laura
Pulver the actress who played Irene in
season two said that she might be coming
back she didn't say whether she was
talking about season three or season
four but Molly more stan is going to be
Sherlock's new best frenemy in this new
season we won't meet her till the second
episode and I don't want to include too
many spoilers but if you want to find
out about her you can watch that
spoilery video I did needless to say
Sherlock's relationship with her will
become very tense and very uncomfortable
in the best possible way and my number
one thing to look forward to this season
in Sherlock the villain so the new
villain is Charles Augustus Magnussen
his name is actually a reference to a
conan doyle villain named Charles
Augustus Milverton who is kind of
described as like the king of
blackmailers so that might give you an
idea of what he'll be doing to Sherlock
in this new season Steven Moffat defined
him is terrifying so he's going to be a
lot of fun to watch but now that you
have some info about the new season let
me know in the comments what you're most
excited to see I'm really looking
forward to the reunion is going to be
very punchy and very hilarious so update
on this week most of the shows i do are
back to normal back to their normal
schedules so all the regular videos i do
will be normal this week tonight is the
mid-season finale of The Walking Dead
you can click here to get that video
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post the video later tonight and you can
click here to get that Sherlock spoiler
video that I mentioned earlier thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives
you